so welcome to the annual Stanford GSB
encore award I and I it's a great it's
always a great event every year when I
start with a couple of thanks in
particular to the Encore Award selection
committee for their great choice and
also for their work in putting together
today tonight's event and thank you to
all the sponsors of this event and thank
you to all of our alumni and
distinguished guests thanks for all of
your support of the GSB including coming
tonight so the Encore award we have this
is a award that has been given out since
1977 we've recognized 40 companies over
that time it's given each year to the
entrepreneurial company of the year that
demonstrates the spirit and innovation
and culture of Silicon Valley companies
and this year work day is a fabulous
selection and we have the two
co-founders of work day here with us
tonight and yobu Suri and Dave Duffield
and I'll bring them out in a few minutes
and just to say a few words to of
introduction this is a particularly
fitting award for Stanford to recognize
an entrepreneurial company because it is
so entrepreneurship and innovation are
so central to the to the University and
to the business school these days every
single one of the MBA students at the
Stanford Business School has been taking
at least one entrepreneurship class and
in the last few years about 15 or 20
percent of our students in fact go on
immediately after graduation and start a
company that's the next Business School
has about 7% and everyone else is at
about three so that is really a
distinctive feature of Stanford and of
course all of the students become so
much more innovative and able to assess
risk and opportunity and be more capable
leaders by being exposed to
entrepreneurship and absorbing the the
culture here at Stanford and it's a way
that we connect with the rest of the
university with engineering and medicine
and education earth sciences that you
know integration with the other schools
the real home
mark of what we what we do and in a if
you look at what's happened in our
entrepreneurship or in the last few
years one of the big things that we've
seen is a enormous increase in students
interested in social entrepreneurship
that is using the skills of
entrepreneurship and innovation in areas
like health and education and
sustainability as a way to think about
using innovation to address fundamental
societal challenges last year we we
actually had a hundred and forty
students who participated in a social
entrepreneurship or social
entrepreneurship program and when I
think about you know looking forward one
thing I think you're going to hear about
tonight is that many of us anticipate
that there's gonna be profound changes
in business and in society as a result
of advances in technology and in
particular automation data science
social intelligence and that is I
believe that is likely to be one of the
areas where our entrepreneurship program
goes over the next several years both in
terms of thinking about what the
opportunities are and also the potential
risks and consequences and I think I
think you'll hear so that's not because
the two people who are the leaders and
founders of workday are famous for being
one step ahead of technology and seeing
what are the opportunities that are
enabled by a you know an in their case
new communication the internet and new
to communication technology and then of
course masterful execution which they
have actually done exceptionally
exceptionally well okay
so now I want to introduce that I want
to bring out our panelists tonight and
I'm gonna let see if they just you want
to brew see if they can if they're here
we'll bring them bring them out Jeff
come on out okay so so we've got between
four of them we have two panelists and
we have two moderators we're gonna
double-team the panelists from either
end here and the we have a yang on each
end
and they're gonna have some jokes about
that I think I so first on the far end
we have Jeff yang he's a MBA graduate of
class of 85 he is the founding partner
of redpoint ventures he has invested in
in many technology companies through
through redpoint he did not invest in
work day and so maybe they'll they'll
discuss why that I mean what happened
there but I'm I it's not on their list
jeff has also just been an incredible
volunteer and alumni supporter of the
Business School since he graduate has
been on our Advisory Council he's a been
a longtime chair of the I Corps
selection committee and he's involved
across the university in many many ways
here next to me is Jerry Yang Jerry's a
Stanford graduate he got both bachelor's
and a master's degree over in the
engineering school graduate in 1990 and
somehow never made his way over to the
business school but that's okay
he left Stanford to found Yahoo that was
you know back in the early days of the
internet and and of course was was
involved there until 20 until 2012 and
Jerry not only was he a the internet
pioneer he probably made one of the
all-time great investments by buying 40%
of Alibaba in 2007 so he's distinctive
as a founder and also as an
entrepreneurial investor and he also has
been incredibly involved with Stanford
he's on our board of trustees he's been
on the advisory boards of the knight
Hennessy Scholars the Cantor Art Center
and he's currently involved in our new
human centered artificial intelligence
initiative so Jeff and Jerry thank you
so much for your leadership and support
here at Stanford and out of the
community
[Applause]
okay now into panelists and Yoko Sri and
Dave Duffield Anil is a GSB alum from
the MBA class of 1993 he left he went to
work for David PeopleSoft he eventually
became vice chairman there and they
started work day together in 2005 after
the acquisition of PeopleSoft by Oracle
and it's been a home run basically from
day one
under Neil's leadership as CEO and
you're gonna hear all about it
and Neal's also on the board of
directors of Intel and I want to welcome
the other directors of Intel who decided
to spend their board dinner here
listening to a meal so thank you all so
directors of himself and then Dave
Duffield in the in the middle here has
been a just a legendary technology
founder and leader for many years he
co-founded workday he's the chairman of
the board and before that he founded
co-founded PeopleSoft he was the CEO of
that company and before that he was the
CEO of integral systems he founded
information associates there's not very
many people in the world with his record
of entrepreneurial complement so it's
really really a privilege to have Dave
make the trip to be here tonight so
thank you all and looking really part of
the panel thank you John
before we get started I just want to
thank Jerry Yang for joining us and you
know we make many yang sandwiches but
this is by far the most distinguished
yang sandwich that we don't have before
we get started can I just say that one
of them is good Yang and one of them's
bad yang and you guys will have to
figure out who is who we're a little bit
like matter and antimatter we can't
occupy the same space in any event I
just wanted to talk for a minute about
the the Encore selection committee why
we selected work day as our as the
winner of the Stanford entrepreneurial
company the Year award you know part of
the story goes to you know we look for
very classical stories of
entrepreneurship and any work days a
company that was founded by two
previously successful entrepreneurs who
work together were friends and started a
company
over breakfast in February 2005 with a
piece of paper the second is that we
look for founders who are still involved
with the company and and there's still
the CEO and the chairman respectively
and and obviously very actively involved
and today workday is the leading
provider of enterprise cloud apps for
finance and HR with over 2,400 customers
and 10,000 employees worldwide and over
35% of the Fortune 100 run workday and
that number grows every day thanks to
their efforts the company went public in
October of 2012 at $28 and it closed
today it almost six times that price
over a hundred and sixty four dollars
with a market cap of 36 billion dollars
since its IPO subscription revenues have
grown from approximately 130 million
dollars in the year that you went public
to an estimated 2.3 billion in the
current fiscal year representing an
annual growth year over year 30 percent
which is kind of astonishing finally
Anil is a very loyal Stanford GSB grad
and as you can tell one of the most
beloved members of our community yeah
and if you're not sure just look around
there we've had more table sales from
sponsors and Friends than any other
Award winner and in recent memory so why
do we select workday well that's why and
so thank you and welcome to nailing day
so we thought we would just kind of talk
through a few issues and then we'll open
it up for questions at the end but maybe
we can start with Anil with the founding
of workday and you worked you both work
together PeopleSoft and your friends but
talk a little bit more about kind of how
you met and how your friendship
developed and then talk about how
PeopleSoft and what was happening
PeopleSoft led to the founding of
workday
sure so uh one little thing I forgot to
mention we were fashioned trendsetters
I'm wearing the tied a nail bought the
management team for our IPO
really you've got actually was Lindsay
who's on the flag we got matching
watches matching watches they go very
very nice matching watches and Anil got
me that several months ago and I've got
something for you I'll open it later
yeah it's relevant and you I peoplesoft
watch desert collector items so I first
met Dave in 1992 I was working for
George still over there who I owe a lot
to George George picked my name out of a
resume book when I was at Stanford
Business School I was gonna go work at
Microsoft for the summer I said went to
work for George because we had one hour
breakfast that turned into three hours
George was the only investor in
PeopleSoft I went to PeopleSoft board
meeting a year later when I was
graduating from the GSB I was about to
go into venture capital I thought I
wanted to work for a company and so Dave
said George said go see Dave you know go
see Dave and he'll figure out a job for
you and so I went to go see Dave and at
this point PeopleSoft was already a
successful public company not the huge
company that it ended up being and Dave
took me out for a beer it's got the
seafood I remember that vividly and
here's this famous entrepreneur taking a
MBA out for a drink we had a glass of
chardonnay which we now have a lot of
those together and said yeah come work
for me I don't know I'm gonna do with
you yet why don't you take three or four
months off and travel and I'll figure it
out by the time you get back that's what
he said and I thought wow this famous
CEO and entrepreneur when took me out
for a beer I really know I'm not really
that excited about HR software but
try for a couple years and you know 26
year later I'm an HR software so that's
that's that's how we met and we've been
best friends since yeah but we well he
was 20-something so what was your first
impression and how how did that don't be
so skeptical Jerry you know we we were
linked many many years ago we were both
double e's yeah we I
I went to high school in Ridgewood New
Jersey and Neil was born in Ridgewood
New Jersey wonderful mom sitting out in
front here our dads both worked for Bell
Labs and we my first job was in
Rochester New York and he'll and his
family spent several years there so we
were connected well before you and I met
on that eventful day but I saw in this
young man a just in energy an
intelligence of a desire to to learn to
listen I wanted to do something
obviously he had great your attentions
we are a fast-growing company at that
time and plenty of things to do and we
connected personally and it's truly been
a love affair you know for 26 years now
okay so now you're you're you're in
PeopleSoft you're working together tell
us about what happened that that drew
you away from PeopleSoft to start
workday well so it was 1999 and I think
you decided that it was it was time for
you to take a step back the board
decided that I wasn't ready to be the
next CEO which I totally agree with I
wasn't someone argue I'm still not ready
and we went out inside and found an
outside CEO to run PeopleSoft but both
Dave and I stayed on the board
fast forward to 2003 and Oracle launched
a hostile takeover on work on PeopleSoft
halfway through that hostile takeover
the board fired that CEO and brought
Dave and I back
to try to save the company from from
Oracle we obviously didn't prevail but
we had so much fun working together in
the middle of a hostile takeover and
along that way we did actually we had so
much it
we had a glorious time and I remember
requiring the company acquired JD
Edwards remember that in June I think it
was 2003 and that launched the hospital
takeover by Oracle I have a fun story
let me finish that welcome back that
along the way we we came to conclusion
that what PeopleSoft was doing had had
hit a wall and there was a better way
and you know I I was friends with Marc
Benioff at the time and thought we both
thought someone's gonna do what
Salesforce is doing for sales and
marketing for HR and Finance miles will
be PeopleSoft of course then it didn't
end up being PeopleSoft and they took
over they took over PeopleSoft they
didn't want me and Dave those you know
since we can fought it didn't even have
shocking but they didn't ask him they
didn't ask for non-competes and so it
was a bad decision so three months later
I just start working on that on that
idea but really now now finish the part
but we both went back with for no pay if
you remember that and $1 actually I
didn't get the dog I got the dollar but
you just put yourself in our place where
the board and public company just fired
the CEO and they're in the middle of
this hospital a truly hostile takeover
and we have a wonderful group of venture
capital people here who in their right
mind would go back to work as the CEO or
partner the CEO with without a guarantee
of millions and millions of dollars we
didn't get paid and it was a really a
just a partnership that wanted to do the
right thing for the customers the
employees and I this story I have
Anil went back and created this product
vision we went out on the road to talk
to the analysts the shareholders he
personally moved the stock from 17
dollars a share to 25 I mean personally
the value of the company went up 50% in
my job was sort of go around to talk to
people one of my visits was to Denver to
JD Edwards where we just acquired 5,000
employees and had the occasion to go and
speak to the whole company
so all this CEO I'd McVeigh knees do you
remember him in the elevator and he said
Dave this is sort of funny Dave we
decided as a company we needed to
explore our options and the options one
of the options was get acquired and so I
and McVeigh knee to talk to all our
employees in Denver a couple of thousand
of them he said team we have to explore
this option how would you guys feel
about being acquired by s AP yes
terrible worst decision you could make
ad terrible okay
well then hop out if we got acquired by
Oracle even worse hysterics people
leaving the room they couldn't believe
that then he says what about being
acquired by PeopleSoft just like the
room here maybe that's an option you
know Dave you know what we chose people
Clough because you guys aren't a bunch
of
[Laughter]
is it obviously a true story so you guys
are two the nicest people and and I I
wonder do you guys ever argue I mean
tell us about these Chardonnay dinners
we've we've at the end or what happens
in these in 26 years we've never had an
argument or a fight
never so once a month during the
founding a workday we'd go out to dinner
at amber this hole-in-the-wall and in
Danville we learned the meaning of
Cougar juice at one of those dinners my
story and we get a bottle of wine and we
talk through all the issues in the
company and we'd always solve everything
and if we didn't we'd get a second
bottle of wine but never never and I
think part of it is our relationship
with each other is more important than
any one decision and also I think we see
the world generally the same although
I'd say most people think of me as an
optimist and I see the world is
half-full Dave sees a a half-full glass
is completely full that's true and I
think that's the that's the beauty of
workday you know we we took on sa P and
Oracle and there were Press reports
written when we started the company like
who are these guys this is the dumbest
idea no one's going to take on sa P and
Oracle and when they're gonna get killed
you know you need optimism we had a
perfect relationship with one minor
little thing after the we thought hustle
takeover succeeded and we were in an
airport somewhere and I was following a
deal and he was pissy if you you know
what's the matter
he said well you wrote the memo to the
company you spelled Greylock with an A
so that was our only little to only
little tip well there's a great lot of
people here they'd appreciate that so
you've been doing this for 14 years
right what keeps you going what what
keeps what's what's the drive that keeps
you guys still involved and working as
hard as you do well I would say for me
that day Dave was the pioneer of a new
new way of doing business in Silicon
Valley Dave was the first nice guy to be
really successful back and then in the
90s that was not the model
so PeopleSoft was all about taking care
of employees taking care of customers
having fun along the way and workday is
as I think taking it to a new level and
what what we're both proud of is we were
number seven on great place to work
recently but we're a great place to work
for Millennials which is frankly a
really hard group there's we got some of
millennial employees in the audience
women LGBT key diversity everything we
are we just embrace we embrace everyone
and we've created this great place to
work and I think it's a fall through
from from PeopleSoft and it's exciting
to have a place that is you know that's
positive that takes care of its
customers that takes care of its
employees and we're winning and I think
that makes it fun every day right I mean
people are happy at work day we're you
know great place to work we're also at
98 percent customer satisfaction it kind
of fuels each other we got the people
the work day management team here and
they're an amazing team making it all
happen and it's just it's just fun to go
to work and I'll say it's it's it's I
feel like my job is to be the steward of
what they've started I tell you this guy
continues to be innovative I think we
got the customer satisfaction going
first the employees we're also in the
country for working parents that's
pretty cool but we have all that going
for us and yet Anil devotes his energy
to making sure we're taking advantage of
the new technology the new trends he's
got some of the smartest people at work
day working on new stuff so we can keep
our lead and in our technology business
I mean everything is going super well
and to see this guy in front of Cramer
in front of the user conference sales
people it's this recent company meeting
fabulous job in terms of motivation
sense of humor commitment to you know
furthering the customers furthering the
employees to
it's a great spot to be I'm super proud
of him I've been lucky enough to be
close to work day for many years and I
know when you have your user conference
arising every year when Dave Duffield
gets up on stage just like a cult
everybody goes crazy and so you've
always been they've sort of the at least
for me the symbol for being that
customer advocate for a work day and and
as customers have continued to change
and the two of you seem to be able to
see around corners very intuitively and
whether it's product directions whether
it's the proper paranoia whether it's
confidence how do you guys is this just
natural and you guys kind of just feel
it and it happens or is this something
that you guys talk about how does the
process of doing all those things about
building a great product engaging
customers have great employees and have
a great culture is this something that
just kind of comes along naturally or is
this something that you really work hard
at well the culture has to be in the
heart of the founders and that that's
what we stand for the corners I see
around I always ask anneal what's around
the corner that's the way I figure it
out but no he's he's the visionary
petros another luminary at work days in
the second row here just fabulous
visionary - what I learned from Dave in
the very early days at PeopleSoft was to
be a good listener and I learned it the
hard way we went to dinner and Dave
wasn't saying anything and I'm like well
I'm with Dave I'm not gonna say anything
we had this like awkward silence for a
period of time and and I said well Dave
you hadn't say anything it's like well
I'm waiting for you to say something
smart and and he gave him this lesson
which I take to heart not always perfect
at it but no one learned anything while
they were talking so you listen to the
customers he listened to your engineers
she listened to what's happening in the
marketplace and then you try to
synthesize the information to what's
happening but it's out there you just
you just have to listen and that's I
learned that from Dave Dave's one of the
best listening
when used to run the PeopleSoft
management meetings he'd be pretty quiet
most of the meeting and then he
summarized at the end what we were gonna
do actually works pretty well so so talk
about you know your I've heard George
still also mentioned you know really
good at look around corner so so look
around the corner and tell us what what
is your vision of what the industry
looks like ten years now and what is
workday what's work days next challenge
that's that's a great question ten years
is hard okay the next five years
[Music]
there's nothing slowing down the cloud
and I think that's a foregone conclusion
when we started the company there were
there were all the naysayers but that's
a foregone conclusion I know everybody
is talking about machine learning and AI
but it is real it's not the bogeyman
that people make it out to be there's a
great book called prediction machines
that was written by three professors in
in at the University of Toronto that
talked about the economics of machine
learning and I think it actually debunks
a lot of the fears basically tells you
that machine learning is great at
predictions humans are not weighted
predictions like we're terrible at
predicting the weather once we know the
weather is bad we make good judgment as
to what to do get an umbrella wear a
raincoat and over time these machines
are going to make better and better
predictions and then humans apply
judgment and that leads to better
outcomes and I actually think that it's
it's actually going to be much more
positive than what people are describing
our applications in five years will
basically predict what's going to happen
on the business side and whether it's an
HR or finance whatever applications
we're building and then the the business
folks will have to take advantage of
that prediction and make a decision on
what they're going to do with that
prediction and hopefully it leads to
better business outcomes so it'll go
from automating processes to predicting
outcomes and actually if you if you talk
to our customers they're looking for
better business decisions and better
outcomes not just automated business
processes so petros has been a big
driver of the investment in itself it's
all about the data but I think that is
big part of it and you know the the
important part for me is that we don't
get up ended by a new a new player I
don't worry about sa P and Oracle I like
to say they're dinosaurs they're
actually proving it out you know one of
the executives that Oracle said you know
we're a dinosaur but we can fly and I'm
like well those died too you know just
saying it's gonna be somebody that
starts with a clean sheet of paper that
looks at workday as as a legacy provider
we're now 14 years old and says this is
the way I would do it if I start with
the clean sheet of paper today and
that's why every few years Petros and I
take our key engineers off site we say
what would you do today what would you
what would you do today to to start
workday knowing the technologies are
available today versus 14 years ago and
then we try to reinvent ourselves and I
think that's what will be what I do know
that in five years or 10 years that the
the culture that Dave built at
PeopleSoft that we built together a
workday I hate to use this word but will
trump strategy right I don't like to use
that word but it will that will matter
more than anything we do if we have the
right culture will be innovative will
have happy employees and happy customers
and the rest will take care of itself we
have a couple of really cool board
members yeah ya know we got George we
got Jerry Jerry someone who actually
sees around corners he told us with what
to do with the board meeting right but
enough about me I you know I knew you
you were an investor for time in made
some incredible investments you're an
incredible operator are those things
different how different are they and how
do you how do you differ device you give
people who are you know investment
community I you know me and Jeff or
people operating how how javi maneuvered
sort of those different kinds so it's
seemingly very different
I've always felt more comfortable being
in a company when I was investor
I love new technology and that applies
to both venture and just like you love
new technology I loved I love the new
technology and venture and I loved the
new technology that we built work day
around that's where the similarities
probably end as a venture capitalist you
need to be a skeptic to be the the
guardrails on a company to make sure
that the entrepreneurs who are so
optimistic that they have some
guardrails to keep them to keep them on
the right Road as entrepreneurs you want
to be optimistic and count on your board
to be the guardrails and I feel I'm
better as the optimist than the
guardrails but I do think it's a mindset
where the best the best investor I've
ever ever worked is in the audience
Dave Z I'm more famous at Greylock for
hiring Dave Z than anything I did
investing it's true he invested in
Facebook and LinkedIn when neither
really look like a short thing right I
mean Dave David's amazing David just can
analyze anything in detail and you know
I think it's it's it's sort of a
different mindset most of my success as
an investor was being part of almost
being part of the founding team mm-hmm
so I do you think it's it's different
yeah so everybody kind of talks about
successes right but some of the best
lessons that you you learn are from
failures can you do you mind talking
about some of your failures and what
you've learned you learned about them
learned from them one failure for me was
picking the wrong successor PeopleSoft
at the time turned out to be brilliant
because in Illinois we've got to go back
to work and become further bonded and
perform work David but that was a
failure of all the business books you
know Jim Collins argues for promoting
from within and I chose to go to the
outside and it didn't work out in
retrospect it did but it was a failure
at the time and now we're now we're now
grateful Larry Ellison for taking over
PeopleSoft because work days done a lot
better than PeopleSoft would have done
so who's our friend right not really but
you know we say that's
what lesson would you derive from that
would you learn from that I don't know
you could get over it move on well but
as many things you guys have kept the
same from PeopleSoft the workday you
guys did make sure in work days the
stock structure that that nobody was
gonna do that to you guys again yeah
that's my my official title here at
workday I'm the hostile takeover
preventer yes I'd say you know when
their stories are written about startups
it's always about how they start from
scratch and went straight to the right
and did did great things and I remember
going on Cramer and he said you guys are
an overnight success like we've been at
it for eight years and the first two
years we couldn't find a single customer
to take workday we were we were working
on it and and finally we want we were
ready to launch the company and we had a
near miss with a big fortune 500
manufacturer we had a near-miss with
Google with Google was now a customer
yeah so then we started calling up all
of our friends and so the first ten
customers were basically friends of
David and Neal who would just try the
software at almost no cost just so we
get at the experience but it took it
took two years to get our first customer
and everybody thinks you know there
must've been easy but people weren't
looking for a new HR or finance system
at the time so when did you know that
you were onto something I mean so so you
go two years and you can't get anybody
to to take the software and and now
you're kind of you got some people on
that when did you know that this is
gonna this is gonna work well our first
customer was a small software company
down in this area there's in very first
customer the CEO of that company was
Khanna software used to be the president
of Oracle North America so we knew we're
onto something there
we're our first customer was a former
competitor I think I think the company
that the event that put us in probably
on the map is flex Tron
they believed in us you know the did Co
CIO at the time they've slowly made the
cover of CIO magazine and so he was
prominent workday was prominent be
because of selling to him turned out to
be a huge success came in under budget
under the budgeted time the whole
company was both Flextronics and and
work they celebrated and absolutely
victory for us not just the cell sales
process but the customer going live in
two hundred thousand employees around
the world so there's a big big success
and a lot of good things happened after
that
yeah and that's see the CEO of
Flextronics ended up joining our board
afterwards and I remember vividly when
we were at the kickoff meeting he told
this whole team we're burning the boats
like Cortes there was no plan B so you
got to make this work and everybody went
quiet in the room including me and Dave
said oh and at this point we could prove
the system could scale to five thousand
employees and they had two hundred
thousand so over the next couple years
Petro some team and the engineers made
it happen but at that point we realized
they didn't have a plan B so we need to
make this make this work and it's been
this great partnership
the CIO went off to be the CIO at
AstraZeneca he became a customer again
you know you take care of your customers
CIOs move around we've had repeat
customers so many times the other one I
would say was Chiquita yep ng yeah so I
you know and you know last year is is a
big year of change for you and and one
of the things I admire about you as a
friend is your cert ability to work life
balance you welcomed a new member to
your family I know Allison's here and
your mom's here I know you had a loss I
mean what when you step back in the
beginning of 2019 today what it last
year being to you but what does that
mean going forward well you know for
those that don't know my mom is in the
audience
I lost my dad a few months ago and you
know he was my hero he was a great dad
my role model you know my to role models
have been my dad and and this guy here
I've always said as my second dad and
that sort of overwhelms everything else
it was a great year for workday but I
miss him a lot and you know I think he'd
be really proud of what Dave and I have
done together
Dave Dave David met him and then we got
a new kid who started off with a little
tough start she came a little early but
now she's doing great so you know that
just it just puts everything into
perspective
I always does and I've got an amazing
wife Allison who's in the audience who's
been through all that with me and who is
a very active and successful angel
investor so you know you should compare
notes on deals Jerry will talk later
maybe maybe have a few minutes just for
some questions from the audience and so
if they're if there's anything that you
want to ask please do so and and
otherwise well we'll keep going any any
questions that I got one so a lot of
people warm so he has bet just everybody
knows he is bad yang and he's good yang
so so now I'm worried that you have an
extra one
yeah actually a funny yang with Robert
says I'm fun yeah yeah I mean I'm sure
you get asked this a lot but but you
know if you had a one or two piece of
advice for a new entrepreneur you've
gone through it a few times and what
would it be
I'd say number one it's way more way
more fun doing it with a friend I think
the story of workday is a story of
friendship I don't think it exists
without the friendship that Dave and
I've had for 26 years 26 years and we've
been working together for 26 years and
the second piece is solve a problem that
matters you know what we set out to do a
workday a lot of people said that's too
hard no one's going to take on sa P and
Oracle so when we were successful we
didn't actually
a whole bunch of other startup
competitors because it was it was hard
and anytime people talk about wanting to
compete with work day and knowing HR and
payroll regulations in 180 countries and
the accounting rules across the globe
you say you know welcome to the swamp
this is really hard stuff and all the
companies that I was fortunate enough to
invest in I saw a few of our
entrepreneurs in the audience or you
know what I see it at Intel if it's not
hard it's frankly not worth doing mm-hmm
and you'll have a lot of competition and
if it's hard and you're solving a
problem that matters you'll find a way
to be successful but and when I come
back to any work day is a story of a
friendship that you know turn into a
great company I totally agree I would do
suggest that the entrepreneur
immediately defined the vision for the
company and I failed to do that for my
first 25 years in business and finally
at PeopleSoft as George knows and Anil
knows we do find our value system our
purpose in life I mean your core values
are most most important you know to get
that right in the beginning
it's the methodology for hiring the top
people in the company you want everybody
to be able to work together and I think
Anil and I did it beautifully at work
day we established our vision we hired
the right people
Petros Jim Pezzini dan sweet a whole
bunch of dynamite people and we were in
harmony we just worked well together we
solve problems together we took on
challenges we were we were good friends
so I think that's number one and it's
just phenomenal to be able to work with
your best friend I still remember the
days then it worked
we had cubicles together we lean over
and Niels was cluttered with all this
electronics has the latest of anything
always fiddling with it and it's his
genius mind at work but it's fun just to
collaborate everybody needs somebody to
talk to you you can't make decisions
without you know thinking through the
you know the different obstacles you
have in front of you there's always
personnel challenges you'll have it your
company and to have your your best
friend next door to talk about things
you could never talk with anybody else
without including your board it's it's
dynamite and we interviewed the first
500 people together only four only for a
cultural fit we assumed the team would
have gotten it right on the skill set
but Dave and I interviewed for a
cultural fit that would be another piece
to you know we set the value system
upfront we spend a lot of the first
breakfast at rec Edina are talking about
the values and then made sure that when
we hired that first five hundred and
many of them ourself to company now
they're the culture carriers to make
sure that we continue down that path
I think founders sometimes punt on
hiring it's easier to let their managers
hire but we were involved with every
every hiring decision for the first 500
that's amazing well listen thank you
very much I've been to a lot of these
and a lot of encore Awards but this is
probably the most human presentation
I've ever I can ever recall so thank you
and it's nice it's nice to see the nice
guys can finish first so thank you very
much and congratulations
[Applause]
jerry various brief thank you all thank
Jeff and Jerry thank you so much for
moderating and David and Neil that was
just seeing the partnership you have was
worth the every minute if that was
wonderful just beautiful so we now have
your your award so here it is
[Laughter]